nous sommes pas étonnés si je vous dis
que ce budget ce cinquième budget du
ministre l'état au regard des
l'épaisseur du budget est un budget
électoraliste nous sommes à quelques
mois des élections et donc on a ouvert
les vannes des dépenses les dépenses de
mission qui ont augmenté de 6 et demi
pour cent au cours du dernier exercice
augmente encore de 4,7 pour cent des
dépenses de programmes de 5,9 pour cent
de simplement vous rappeler que dans les
années d'austérité ou de rigueur
budgétaire on est en bas de 1%
en général sur les dépenses donc là on
est davantage dans du 4 5 6%
vraiment on met beaucoup d'argent pour à
peu près tout le monde pensait à qui
vous aide dans la société
un étudiant un aîné un travailleurs
expérimentés votre partie d'une famille
vous êtes un aidant naturel il ya de
l'argent pour tout le monde dans ce
budget qui a été présenté et donc ça on
se pose des questions sur la prudence du
ministre
en quelque sorte qui va chercher
beaucoup d'argent dans ce qu'on appelle
la réserve de stabilisation la plus de 5
milliards dans la réserve de
stabilisation et on va chercher 3
milliards dans les prochaines années ce
sont haussés de l'argent qui vient des
surplus des derniers budgets qui ont
décidé de l'investir dès maintenant donc
beaucoup de questions qui se posent là
dessus mais pas vraiment de mesures pour
faire face à la réforme fiscale du
président rome où l'incertitude sur les
nerfs mais a quand même des baisses
d'impôts pour les pme au cours des
prochaines années
de l'argent pour répondre aussi à la
question de la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
mais encore là les organismes
manufacturier est ici on aurait aimé que
l'argent sort plus rapidement qu il y a
un plan beaucoup plus rapide pour
répondre à cette pénurie de main
d'oeuvre qui ralentit présentement
l'économie à noter qu'il y à une baisse
de taxes pour les institutions
financières une baisse de taxes pour les
banques est à noter également que le
gouvernement va de l'avant avec la
décision de demander aux géants
numérique de l'étranger et du canada de
l'extérieur du québec en fait de
percevoir la tvq la taxe de vente du
québec lorsqu'ils vendent au québec cela
dit ça va pas rapporter autant que ce
qu'on perd présentement budget
électoraliste
on se tait et on se laisse ça tue parce
qu'essentiellement sais ce que c'est